ich glaube dass der Bundeskanzler auch
mit der Mehrheit der SPD immer noch der
Auffassung ist dass bei allem was
geschehen ist Russland für die
Sicherheit Europas mhm wichtiger war ist
und bleibt als all die Staaten zwischen
Deutschland und Russland und darum hat
er will er nie und will bei dieser
wirksamsten Waffe unbedingt nicht dass
sie geliefert wird weil das wiederum
dann das Tischtuch auch von ihm und
Deutschland zu Russland zerschneiden
würde und das will er im Hinblick auf
zukünftige Vorstellungen vermeiden er
sagt ja auch nicht die Ukraine soll
gewinnen er sagt die Ukraine darf nicht
verlieren Russland darf nicht gewinnen
er ist im Grunde seine politische Formel
ist im Grunde drückt sich jetzt in den
militärischen Pat das wir haben aus und
ich glaube seine Vorstellung ist die des
Pad und dann kommen irgendwann
Verhandlungen die das Problem lösen das
ist meine Interpretation